我一用酸就變成这样了
冒了很多这种
膨重大动
贝文12年有动几个
我最爱用的
糊皮就是酸
它能让我的皮膚状态苦
四十分变成90分
不管是
道道闭口还是黑头粉
次还是皮膚粗糙
它都能一最快速度帮我解决
但刚开始用酸的时候
用就烂脸
要问就暴动
要问就犯红明明
搞了我很长时间
都不敢用
具有点怀疑人身
你感觉是酸
对豆子到底有用用用
后来我的皮膚可以生就熟把手交我
就酸方法
我一直用到现在
真想它让我的皮膚状态
真正变得超好
你们一天就懂了
再用全就不会反成了
利益脸上现在有很多
避口粉次的话
先别用酸
因为酸是会加速皮膚
但线的
你的避口一碰上酸
就很容易变成红豆打斗
直接你们看想过以前的照片
这是我以前的脸
就是很多很多那个
密密码
觉得不都是避口粉次
我一用酸就变成这样了
冒了很多这种
膨重大动
这就是大家
你用酸就爆斗烂脸的原因
用酸之前先做一个蒸清
把它脸上现在有的
斗斗必口粉次
一次性全部清掉
再去用酸就会避过这个烂脸期
有的博物就会说
你们就熬过这个烂脸期就好了
熬到后面就不会爆斗的
这也是一个方法
但是我不醒了
我受不了我的脸
每天都在爆那种种斗斗
第二就是避开脚
是层寶的区域用酸
我自己讲的是层罪寶
就是在全顾这里
所以我每次用酸翻车
就是这两头变成的高原模
很痛很痛
酸本来就是加速脚制波图的
脚制寶的区域用酸
就会更薄
那当然就会饭红明明了
所以用酸就避开脸上脚
这层寶的区域用了
我观察一下
大部分
我们这样做的女生
这一天都很薄
我也不知道为什么
而且怎么一样都感觉一样不后
第三就是循序健庆
我以前很着急
因为我听说能度越高
它的效果就越快
我第一次用酸直接就上得很获
结果就是我那时候翻车了
后来我就先用柱口的酸去
经历那时候效果也很好
而且也没有在翻车过了
接下来就是分享我的爱用酸
有停架的
你有稍微贵一点点的
有适合新手入门的
也有老手会超爱的
那先分享一个入门系列的
这个都是我从二二面
就开始用着二面
就跟你们分享过一次的
超温和里面就是百分之零点目的是一样酸
虽然温和
但是用能用出效果
我自己用三个了六年
那种很高努力的
我现在都可以用
但是我会给我投用它
我还是会觉得很好用
有效果
我现在再就刚好干手干的
我就把它给用上
它虽然不是那种
一也会穿行选手
但是每次付款
它还是感觉皮膚会软软的
摸破有很酱进行
它的这个使用感特别好
就是这种非常轻爽的
有利制顶
接下来我就会扶着它
然后跟你的渐烧后面的酸
那新手寶贝
刚开始躲家庭班
就把它就可以选它
第二个将来就很复拔
我现在做我家庭班
还没有用你的酸动
我就只用它
它就是快很准的
也会一穿洗代表
别的酸动模一般
都要复时到15分钟
为什么我今天发
这个复尚脸
就认为这个复碗
时候可以很就不用洗掉
我就可以继续给民度
这一支你复尚脸
一两分钟
就可以倒定了
特有一个特别的省事件
而且一两分钟
它就可以让我的脸换下去
它叫多酸精华
你给不止有干纯酸
还有水洋酸酸酸酸酸
干纯酸可以把我们皮膚表面的那种
老费的粗糙的脚致
赶快带下掉
让皮膚快速的回复到
一个心意光滑的脚致
水洋酸就可以深入到毛孔里面
做梳通做大嫂厨
这里的时候
30-20多多
人二三对红洞的项目
有非常好
很美次用的
它的第二天
我就觉得我的皮膚
很嫩很嫩
就像小悲一样的
毛孔在视觉上
就会看起来
很嫩的小的一鞋
这支做
如果你是弄三老手
一定一定要试试它
虽然了本
但是真的会让你很紧
再一个就是皮膚肉的比较多的
酸酸
它是净测水
它都是那种外霧系务身的
我分享的其他几支
它们都不教室和外上用
这个白天用
可以让妆胆跟腐贴
白天的出友会減少
晚上用可以打开皮膚通宝
让后续的护服平更好的
被皮膚吃进去
里面有水洋酸
但是它负败的
很多很多的胸户维维维的部分
所以新手用它
是完全没问题的
我和喜欢把它
倒在脸片上的
然后来轻轻的
它是皮膚
对于粉丝闭口的
改善效果非常硬性
而且这脸片它卖脸
这话还可以用来插薄
最后备
我用了它之后
我后边上的豆豆
豆硬真的好很多
最后就是这一形
它试着当中最具理品
但是
真的让你会很经验
我只要晚上用了它
早上起床
我都觉得我正张脸
都在发光
就好像前一天去做了什么
千月四百两
它也是很猛的
里面有六种酸
所以必口黑头豆豆
皮膚除操在它面前都
一直一批
对然会晓贵
但是用量很深
我一般用个量低
它就可以把我整个脸
两滴的效果
第二天就足以让你激烈
所以需要稍微贵一点
可以用很重
我刚才分享
这么多款在你们选合
是自己的就可以了
因为那一款
都可以帮我们一只豆豆
还一头必口
好 这后来一个婚续
看一下我刚刚把
这个酸洞模细碗的皮膚状态
虽然它平价
溫和但是效果也是特别好的